let's go to our caller from the 6:00 to
6:00 area code who's calling today from
6:00 to 6:00 hello yes that's you hello
yes that's you yeah hello Dave my name
is Steve I'm from Azusa hey Steve
California yeah I'm a new listener my
question I had a couple of them
basically would the Senate being the way
they are
even with this impeachment going to that
point they're not gonna vote for it so I
mean isn't this basically just an
election type of move the Democrat and
why don't the Democrats play a little
bit tougher I mean I was just watching
on MSNBC and CNN how Trump has just got
so much bad stuff in this past let's
let's think this through Steve when you
say why can't Democrats be tougher what
do you mean what do you want him to do
oh no no I don't want him to do anything
I'm just saying he is so just outright
dirty about everything lying and
everything and why don't the Democrats
like I don't have to lie but they need
to expose these lies and play on the
more so they're just giving a little bit
of airtime and then letting it go listen
I don't I don't agree with you in the
sense that just pointing out that Donald
Trump lies has not been very effective
because Donald Trump has pre-empted a
lot of that by saying it's all fake news
he's done really good job of that so
whenever we say hey look there's five
things Trump lied about the his
supporters don't care so my hope is that
the impeachment inquiry if it's carried
out correctly will expose the country
not to Trump lied because he lies all
the time and that that's not moving the
needle but this this is a person who is
a systemic danger to the country and you
should vote for someone else in November
of 2020 that's the hope I don't know
that it will happen yeah yeah exactly
yeah I'm hoping did it just seems that
they're just so blind the people on the
right that this is this is so ridiculous
I can i couldn't believe in other four
years if it does happen
yep and
may well it may well sadly Steve oh boy
hey the other thing David what do you
think about climate change and the way
that we're racing toward an extinction
and it's almost as if once again fossil
fuels I mean they kill so many people
just all these different things that are
bad and yet they're getting pushed
forward and the things they're just
saying all cost too much to do this cost
too much I mean there's a lot of is in
there but you know this is obviously one
of the foremost this is one of the top
three issues of our time and you know
we've talked a lot about it and it's
extraordinarily disheartening what's
going on Steve great to hear from you I
hope to hear from you again let me take
a quick break but if you're holding on
to talk to me don't hang up because I
will go right back to the phones after
this